certainly we were disappointed along the
way and frustrated that something more
substantial hadn't been done
a clark county employee who worked with
journalist jeff german to expose
problems within the public
administrator's office sitting down with
the eight news now investigators
and thank you for joining us at six i'm
brian loftis and i'm denise valdez
tomorrow robert tell us who's accused of
killing jeff gearman as a result of
those stories is in court now here rita
reed is telling vanessa murphy about her
hopes for that appearance
robert keller on the eve of another
court appearance for accused killer
robert tellis rita reid says she's
hoping the judge keeps him in custody
what would it mean for you
if he is able to post bond
be frightening
and be frightening
tell us the clark county public
administrator is accused of murdering
review journal investigative reporter
jeff gearman jeff is
and feel
so strongly about
he actually listened reed is the
assistant public administrator she and
other employees worked with german to
expose problems under the leadership of
telus reed ran against telus and beat
him in the democratic primary she faces
a republican to win the seat in november
our goal was to get our office back on
track she says complaints to the county
and union about telus bullying employees
went nowhere he became more emboldened
in his behavior and treatment and she
saw a side to tell us which she says
most people haven't i saw tremendous
rage there were several incidences where
he came into my office
in a rage
and i
in the circumstances didn't warrant that
at all when the work environment
continued to be toxic you're working on
pins and needles and you hear footsteps
coming in and so you tense up she says
she and her co-workers turned to gearman
they exposed a possible inappropriate
relationship with the subordinate telus
made social media posts critical of the
stories and then on september 3rd
gearman was found stabbed to death
outside his home did you suspect rob
immediately immediately immediately
metro police say dna found underneath
gearman's nails matches telus and the
elected official's suv shoes and
clothing are also tied to the scene you
ever feel a physical threat from him
there i was very intimidated i think
many people were she says she and german
told each other to be safe but she never
imagined his work would cost him his
life
jeff was
so amazing for us and for our department
and to this community and we will
forever be grateful in las vegas vanessa
murphy 8 news now